good morning Hank it's Tuesday it is the
second to last day of pizza Miss I can
see your arms which a little bit kills
the illusion
it's Hank Green everybody you're in my
light
you're in my life do you know what light
is kind of don't know what light is
don't tell me we don't know what light
is that's like what I found out we don't
know why there is matter in the universe
that's a real problem for me but you
know it's not a problem for me hydration
thanks to my pizza John now Gene bottle
I waited till near the end of pizza Mist
to show y'all look at it Hank oh wow
Paul wants to know should I install Tick
Tock
I mean don't ask me whether you should
try hard drugs if you've got not if
you've gotten this far I think you're
good but you know what I would install
Paul I would install a pizza John bust
in your home oh my God
oh my God pizzamist.com go on
Hank it used to be you who were so good
at advertising and marketing
when did I become the seller I need I
need you next year I want to do one of
these but Pizza I love these These are
so fun and you can turn them into all
kinds of shapes like this shape oh I did
a magic he did a Magic Maddie wants to
know do you actually have to separate
lights and darks while washing clothes
so if I've washed a red item of clothing
like a pizza John shirt four times then
I'm like I mean I'm out that's enough
that's done Reagan wants to know what
pizza Miss shirt should I buy if I can
only buy one great question Reagan glad
you asked I can't tell you which pizza
John shirt to buy Reagan it's like
asking me to choose which of my kids I
love more but um I can tell you which
ones my kids chose uh my daughter Alice
chose square pizza me yeah it's a box
pizza box and my son Henry chose
if it rides Our Lives I just had a
meeting with my Tick Tock person yeah
there's a person at Tick Tock who
handles my account I'm clearly a low
priority for her but she was very nice
and uh she was like here are your four
least performing videos over the last
two months as you can see your cars
versus series was not a hit and I was
like oh contraire by the way I met the
person who designed this shirt last
night too Andrew wants to know thoughts
on my pizza John Bento oh God it's great
phenomenal I mean I've seen a lot of
pizza John pizzas which are all amazing
but this pizza John Bento might take the
pizza I can't say take the cake drink
Pizza it's not allowed no it's
problematic Steven asks where would you
rank the importance of the creation of
social media against the detriment it
can cause
it's a great question Stephen
you know where I've come down on this
where it doesn't matter because we can't
get rid of it so
right I don't know if the button was
there to turn it off then I'd need to
know the answer to the question but the
button's not there we can see parallels
when we look at the printing press and
when we look at the proliferation of
newspapers we created norms and also
regulations like laws to make those
Technologies work better for us and
hopefully by looking at what has
happened in the past we'll be better at
doing that more quickly because we have
to do it more quickly because it's
changing so much faster Maureen Johnson
wants to know how do I write a book not
you me well I certainly don't know how
Maureen should write a book Maureen has
written a lot more of them than I have
didn't she write some books like sitting
across the table from you yeah she wrote
Sweet Scarlet while I was writing Paper
Towns across the table from her so maybe
that's how maybe we just need to reunite
and write more books while staring at
each other Maureen at a cupcake
restaurant in New York City that clearly
doesn't want us there because we've paid
two dollars for a cup of coffee and
installed ourselves for six hours I
can't wait to see what wonders you bring
me tomorrow but in the meantime happy
Pizza miss everybody and pizzamist.com
get your pizza Miss soccer jerseys they
disappear forever